الكثير من الاشخاص يرغبون في تقليل تناول
الاطعمه عاليه السعرات اما للحفاظ على
الجسد رشيق او
حاول او في محاوله منهم لخساره الوزن
والدهون الزائده انت ما عندك مشكله يعني
انت لازم تزيد وزنك دراسه جديده كشفت
تقنيه تعتمد على التصور والتخيل للمساعده
في تقليل الخيارات الطعام عالي السعرات
وفق ما نشرته دوريه
النتائج اشارت الى ان اولئك الذين يتخيلون
الاطعمه ذات السعرات الحراريه العاليه ثم
يتخيلون التخلص من الطعام بدفعه افادوا
بانهم قللوا من الرغبه الشديده في تناول
الاطعمه الدهنيه
اعاده التدريب التخيلي هو علاج سلوكي
يحاول اولا اثاره حاله مزاجيه سلبيه ثم
يطلب من الفرد تخيل طعام المفضل في
السعرات الحراريه العاليه
ثم للتخلص منه بينما يقوم بايماءه الفعل
الجسدي للتخلص منه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات